i do want to mention and we'll get into
this a little bit later on
that the girl scouts right now the girl
scouts of america
are pushing an anti-racism guy they're
pushing a guide that is being formed by
critical race theory
and these kind of insane leftist race
racial views
a missouri school district right now is
paying
15 000 to a critical race theory
professor
for an audit of the curriculum don't let
them tell you that
that critical race theory is not being
taught in elementary schools and middle
schools okay
that is the focus but there are a lot of
other problems in this country
you know killing babies that can suck
their own thumb that seems like a big
problem
you know of forcing people to take
experimental drugs if they're not at
great risk of a virus shutting down the
whole country shutting down our churches
taking away people's constitutional
rights that's that's a big problem
those are big problems too there are
more problems i think than just race and
if we're only going to focus on race
then i know it seems paradoxical to
people on the left
but actually racial relations are going
to hit
decades long lows not
very good stuff maybe we should focus on
some of the other problems too and then
maybe
we'll have a country that that improves
across all of these levels
i'm so glad that you liked that clip
i am honored i am pleased i'm flattered
if you want to watch the whole show go
check it out it's called helter
skelter's here again
it is on youtube you can ring the bell
subscribe get the notifications
hopefully sometimes these guys don't
send the notifications out for our show
wonder why you can also get it at apple
podcast spotify google play stitcher
michael knowles show you can subscribe
leave a five star review and you can
also order the number one national
bestselling book speechless
controlling words controlling minds
check it out
and i'll see you next time
[Music]
you